the way to work out who the highest
agency person in your life is you are
trapped in some South American jail and
you're about to be transported somewhere
where no one's going to be able to get
you back you have 24 hours and you only
have one phone call to ring somebody to
come and get you out who's that person
that you ring
o Prince
William I feel like you've broken the
game a little bit there I don't think
that was that was perfectly fair you
know my framework though was find
someone that is both smart and
influential M of the royal family yeah
and that cares enough about my
predicament yeah so but that that the
the framework that you come up with
there if you don't know the Future King
of England is someone that is able to
think on their own that doesn't need
instruction that is going to be able to
solve problems at a very high level
Under Pressure very quickly you know
just all of the things that you want in
a friend